Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
September 2nd.
Oh,
happy Labor Day,
everybody.
Huh?
Ou
um,
is it labor day around the world?
If it is happy Labor Day to all you guys out there,
especially ones that make all of our clothes.
Huh?
Everybody in the first world out there.
Come on,
let's have a nice round of applause for this six year old in El Salvador.
Who made you a little cargo pants that you're walking around the cookout with
right now with your big stupid pockets,
your wife's role in her fucking eyes gone.
Why does he keep wearing those shorts?
He hadn't college.
Oh God.
The nineties or over.
Why doesn't he see it?
Why did I end up chopping on his dick instead of that other guys?
Then another guy,
he became a doctor and he wears slacks.
Now.
Um,
for those of you around the world listening to this podcast and my ego tells me
that diverse people around the world,
yet I'll maybe somebody sitting in a bunker,
right?
Listening to this shit over here in the United States,
we have something called Labor Day because we worked so fucking hard in this
country.
[inaudible] number one.
You know why?
Cause we outworked all you.
Yeah.
A bunch of lazy fucking cunts.
Okay.
Actually we did,
according to Tom Brokaw was the greatest generation.
They fucking did everything except raise their kids,
right.
You know,
they raised their kids,
right?
What?
They are reacted to the Vietnam war the way they did not,
they would've gone into the Pacific the same way they did in World War II.
We got a job.
The dough,
it's gotta get done.
No one wants to do it.
Fuck it.
I'm volunteering.
Right.
They were so shell shocked from that.
They couldn't even look at their kids.
And then the kids just grew up all spoiled rotten.
And then all of a sudden it was their turn to go and then they would just say,
Hey man,
like Joan harsh to mellow man.
Right?
And that was the beginning of the end.
I'm telling you right now,
if less people dodge the Vietnam war,
you wouldn't have as many fat people in this fucking country right now.
Okay.
And if you can't do the math on that one,
then you know what,
I can help you.
That's one of my new things is I just make stupid statements to people in bars,
right?
That connect in no way possible.
And as I watched their forehead wrinkle up,
I throw in and if you can't do the math,
then I can't help you.
It's a fucking wonderful game because it,
it,
it puts somebody,
remember when you were like in,
in like junior high grade school,
junior high or whatever,
and kids started talking about sex and they would be like,
do you know what this is?
And you had no idea,
but you didn't want to admit to it.
You know,
cause you didn't want to be the kid who didn't know,
even though nobody was fucking anything at that point.
Right.
But you just didn't want to be the dummy.
That's what I'm tapping into.
All right.
And if you can't do the math on that,
then I can't help you.
I'm telling you,
you got,
and when you say I can't help you,
he got to look away and just let them sit with that,
you know,
just sitting with it.
But that didn't make any sense.
Why should I let it go?
He,
anybody else noticing that?
Ah,
I don't know what it means.
Um,
anyways,
Labor Day.
I don't know what the history of it is.
I'm sure I could look it up on Wikipedia,
but so could you,
you know what am I?
You're fucking reader.
Do you want me to do it?
Cause I,
I will,
I'll look it up right now.
I'll fucking click on this right here,
right?
And then I'm going to type in Labor Day l a.
M.
B.
E R.
T.
O.
R.
Jesus Christ.
Labor Day history.
What is the history of Labor Day?
You know,
there's gonna be something horrific.
Labor Day politics,
history begins with worker strikes and 1890.
So you know what you knew there was going to be some sort of bloodshed.
My,
and then we all forget,
years later we're just sitting around a fucking big green egg smoking a big pork
shoulder,
which is what I'm doing right now.
A,
uh,
Rosebowl legend Jason Law head will be joining the,
um,
I,
I should really clarify that.
Rosebowl tailgate legend.
I keep calling this legends like we're actually out there playing the game.
Oh look at that.
An advertisement for Hertz rental car.
You know what?
I think I'm actually going to switch to them.
This is free advertising for those cons because whenever I go to the airport and
I'm waiting for fucking budget,
those Douche bags,
I think they have one bus at every airport.
And I've really tried to sit there and be like,
okay,
am I just impatient?
And so I just started counting buses and I got to tell you,
Hertz and Avis,
they got a lot of buses,
national and Alamo.
They're kind of like a,
I dunno,
they're from the other side of the tracks.
You know,
they didn't come from money,
but they're working their way up.
They got to share a bus,
you know,
but it's building character over.
There's a lot of character or at Alamo and a national,
but I'll tell you,
budget,
budget wasn't raised right.
He need to stay away from them.
I've had it with those cuts.
We had it with my belt,
with them for fucking ever.
I've had it with them.
All right.
Labor Day's political history begins with worker strikes and eight to in the
1890s yeah.
This is when,
why we had sweatshop labor over here,
which is why we created unions so that they would stop.
And then the unions literally became the fucking thing that they were fighting.
All right?
Lean in on shovels,
some on break and all that fucking thing.
Taken advantage of it.
And then the corporate client said,
Oh yeah,
well,
you know,
good luck to you and your union would taking the factory to another country.
Go on strike all you want.
We're still making money.
All right,
there you go.
Like the Maginot line,
they flew right over the fucker.
So now here we are.
All right.
And that poor guy in rage against the machines got to bring his Ukulele all over
the fucking country to try and get the people of this nation refocus on what the
purpose of a union is.
Because all those,
hey man,
people,
they all had kids.
They all had kids.
All right?
And then they joined unions and then everything left.
All right.
And Cue can't do the fucking math on that.
Then I can't help you feel that I just walked away and I can't help.
Um,
Labor Day has fallen upon us once again.
Oh,
this guy,
what a writer has it really fallen upon us,
has its graced itself with its,
with our graced ourselves with its presence.
Is that how we say it?
Labor Day has fallen upon us.
Once again,
I would love to look up the Douche bag who wrote this and find out how many
fucking articles he started that way,
you know,
just the way this does this hacky standup comics is also hacky writers.
Like,
I refuse.
Ooh,
do you bill?
Are you really refusing?
Can you feel the world shaking in its fucking boots?
Um,
fuck you.
I have my or my,
my,
I have my standards that I live by.
I like to think piece of shit standards,
but standards done the left.
Um,
I don't,
I refuse to read any celebrity interview that begins with what they're eating.
I think that's the hackiest way to,
I've married a zillion to Ed John Travolta,
you know,
breaks into some fucking medium rare steak wearing a smart button down.
Shut the fuck up and just ask him what it was like to be in dance fever.
All right.
Just say,
Hey,
I'm a star fucker and I can't believe I get to sit across in this ICAD.
It's amazing that when he eats,
he also gets shit on his face.
You wouldn't think that from an Oscar.
Um,
all right.
For most Americans,
we're back to the article now.
This means little more than the end of the summer.
Oh,
really?
You got to talk down to me right at the beginning of the fucking article,
Joseph,
if you fucking horn rimmed glasses from the 80s.
All right.
For most Americans,
this means a little more than the end of the summer social season.
Oh,
well,
you know he's actually right because I did have to look this thing up.
Kids and college students alike returned to school,
leaving relieved parents to grasp some sense of normalcy.
Yeah.
Jesus.
It to be more fucking dramatic.
Uh,
cookouts,
flare on and friends get together for cool drinks after some outdoor fund.
Was this written in the twenties?
Uh,
no because there hasn't been anything racist yet.
We're playing horseshoes back then.
They probably use like a black guy.
They just hammered his head into the ground and use them as like a steak and
nobody said anything wrong with it.
Right?
Isn't that how bad the racism was back then?
I might be wrong on that one.
I don't know.
Alright.
Amid all of the action,
everyone seems to forget that Labor Day,
what Labor Day is all about.
Well for the love of God.
Joseph,
can you get to the fucking point?
We get it.
You know what it is and we don't.
Oh,
what an asshole.
You know what?
In this picture he has his glasses on.
But as I read this,
I picture him taking them off right now to give me a little talking to,
um,
during the late 18 hundreds,
labor leaders labor,
uh,
decided that hardworking Americans deserve the holiday of their own.
In other words,
they felt them getting ready to storm the castle.
This is the old bread and circus.
Um,
after 1894 is monumental Pullman railroad strike,
Congress decided to federalize this holiday.
Ah,
God.
And let me guess.
The fucking morons agreed to it.
Hey,
we wanted equal pay and we wanted some days and hours.
how about we give you a one day off a year?
Is there going to be bear?
Of course it's going to be there.
All you can track.
Oh,
I don't know about that.
Fell sounds pretty good to me.
He's a jolly good fellow and that's the end of it.
They completely lose their focus.
Um,
the Pullman strike has such a wide ranging implication that less than a week
after it ended the president that then,
ah,
fuck,
President Grover Cleveland signed the Labor Day.
Act into law.
Now if you can't fucking do the math on that,
don't you see what's happening at this strike happened and all the fucking
Blueblood Douche bags with their top hats chomping on a cigar bar.
Wow.
Why are walking around like the fucking penguin?
They saw what was coming.
People were like,
we've had it.
We're not going to take this anymore and we'll come for you.
You tuxedo count on a Tuesday.
How much money do you have that you're wearing that getup on a fucking Tuesday.
Right?
Back then they had spats,
right.
Showed up a big long car.
Oh God.
They didn't try to hide it.
So they saw what the fuck was coming and then,
you know Grover Cleveland flow.
Who's kidding who,
how did he get an office?
All those rich cuts.
Right?
So they get them,
hey Grover,
I'm supposed to call me mister president Grover,
get an air wattle your fat ass in here.
You can't listen.
Okay.
Okay if this shit,
what happened at the Pullman strike happens straight across this land.
We're not going to have the money to keep the horse coming in to suck your Dick
while your wife's in the other room.
Do you want that to happen?
Okay.
It was a rhetorical question.
Just listen to us.
Okay.
We need to have a fucking day off for these people.
Just give them one fucking day off or smoke a pork shoulder.
We'll get them a bunch of beer.
That'd be so fat and fucking hung over there.
They'll be good till Christmas.
All right.
Just do this for us so we can keep all the money.
Can you do that forest?
Haven't we done enough for you?
Your fucking name?
Grover Cleveland.
And we still got your,
the Oval Office.
All right,
we ready on to on tow.
Ready?
Right.
Um,
all right.
Sorry.
I think I don't need to read the rest of this.
Isn't that what happened considering then both of US soldiers in federal law
enforcement officers killed a number of strikers.
This was the least that he could do.
Oh yeah.
God forbid you protest that you work in fucking 900 hours a God damn week.
You know,
Jesus Christ.
See,
this is before they had like fucking,
you know,
CNN and Fox News to spin it and all that type of crap.
All he had was word of mouth going around,
you know,
I'm sure they had newspapers.
They have newspaper people read back in the 18 hundreds.
All right.
I know I'm just sounded dumber by the second,
but I,
I think I made some sort of point in there.
I like to think I did.
Uh,
well let's,
let's,
this is actually fascinating to me.
Enough to read some more of Jason's article said his name,
Joseph.
Sorry.
Uh,
minimum wage laws.
We're,
we'll long way off and if one thinks the health insurance is bad now it was
nonexistent then.
Then there was the gilded age is near total lack of workplace sanitation and
fair paste pay standards.
Oh yeah.
Like when they built like the Brooklyn Bridge,
like they average like five guys dying a day a day.
Something crazy because they didn't understand the Benz.
And as they will bring somebody up and they'd start to get it,
were like bring him up quicker.
He's getting sick and then that would be it.
Um,
that was it.
Your Dad went to work and he died,
you know,
there was no 60 minutes,
coming out to fucking help you at Bradley or some Shit.
So he's still around and he died too.
Why do people died on that shelf?
Okay.
Um,
well it's been around for 50 years,
Bill,
but people died in the Brady bunch at this point.
Now Alice is still alive.
I don't know about Sam the butcher.
Mike died.
Okay.
The dead died.
Dad always dies,
you know,
fucking working his ass off.
I'm trying to drop some plans in fucking Florence Henderson coming in with the
world's first mullet.
You know,
what the fuck am I?
Thankfully,
scores of long press.
Labor's eventually got together and formed bunions as individuals.
They were all but powerless to bring about the positive change in large groups,
though they manage to secure the American dream,
not only for themselves,
but for generations to come throughout the 20th century.
Democrats typically favored the interest of non-managed workers while
Republicans catered to administrators and business owners.
Why do you got to throw the Hatfields and McCoys in there?
Ya know,
it's US
versus the 5% of them.
Okay.
Stop with the Yankees.
Red Sox,
shit dammit.
Radicals in both parties often destroyed the chance for reasonable solutions to
come.
Okay,
that's fair to complex financial problems.
But moderate voices often prevailed.
That should explain our country's economic success.
It's success for most of the 19 hundreds.
Well,
I imagined there's more to it than that,
but what the fuck?
So there you go.
People,
there's a little ignorant history on this wonderful fucking day.
And here we are 120 years later.
And,
uh,
I'm sitting around today doing a podcast smoke at a pork shoulder.
I made a fucking apple pie.
Now it's going down.
Calories,
calories will be consumed on this wonderful day.
Um,
you know,
it would be great is if somehow you could just eliminate greed,
envy,
jealousy,
paranoia.
Last basically the seven deadly sins.
Okay?
Look,
I'm far from a fucking perfect person.
Oh Geez.
Um,
but it would be good just at least at that fucking level,
you know,
for brick,
you'd be like,
Hey,
yeah,
we'll making enough money know why we should,
you know,
give you health insurance.
I love that whole fucking myth that if you actually treat workers decently,
like a fucking tee shirt is going to cost $50.
It isn't in order for you to continue maintaining your fucking giant yacht,
it would cost that.
When I was a kid,
you know,
factories would just starting to go overseas,
but they made a lot of shit here and sneakers weren't the equivalent of fucking
$200 or whatever the fuck they said that they were going to be.
It's all bullshit.
I don't buy a fucking word of it.
And,
uh,
then that's it.
All right.
I'm not gonna talk anymore because at this point I'm probably even sounding more
ignorant than usual,
but,
uh,
my gut tells me I'm right.
So go fuck yourselves.
Whoa.
I just bailed out of that one.
Didn't I?
Nice barrel roll right out of a fucking moving car.
Um,
so most of you are probably asking,
not most of you,
but a lot of youth or maybe none of you,
but none of you can call in to tell me nothing.
Thinking the song.
I'm going to go with this and say that you are thinking this shit you probably
want.
And what exactly is a pork shoulder?
You're eating the shoulder of a port.
It's actually the pig's ass,
but you would sell a lot less of them,
I think if you said,
you know,
you know pig ass pig rectum,
some people will go pig.
But that's the closest I'll say.
But uh,
yeah,
we're eating the uh,
the ass of a pig.
We smoking the fucker and it's going to be delish.
Um,
so anyways,
let's get on with the podcast here.
Have you buddy,
do you watch any,
uh,
any of the college football this weekend?
Lie Ahead.
Come on in.
Oh,
look who's here.
I'll tell you buddy.
Huh?
Jump On.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
I got to give it a proper inch or the skill.
You've never been on the podcast,
right?
Ladies and gentlemen,
we have here the living legend.
He's tipping the cap.
I keep saying Rosebowl legend.
It's gotta be a rose bowl.
Uh,
a tailgate legend.
Tailgate legend hall of fame.
Grabbed the microphone right there.
Grab the Mike touchdown in a rose bowl.
Exactly.
But we're built,
we built a program here because when we started thing it was ugly.
It was bad.
I mean we were like three in the Bayesian.
You,
you weren't even there the first tailgate,
the first two years you showed up to the second one,
but you weren't cooking.
You were in another light first year.
I don't think I remember it was being drunk and barnick putting butter on the
stakes with two fingers with his index finger and his middle thing.
Cause we didn't have any utensils doing that today.
And I had this little Hibachi and uh,
I just had met him.
I didn't know how to cook.
I did not a grill or anything like that.
I kept flipping the steak and I heard this guy go,
please,
please stop flipping that.
Hopefully it was an Ohio state fan or no,
that was the second year.
I showed up to this,
this,
this was the first,
the first year.
This is already how long we've been doing this and how I'm starting to feel like
the old man over there.
The first year we went there it was USC versus Penn State.
Fucking Mark Sanchez.
Sanchez was quarterback for USC.
Pete Carroll was still coach Joe Paternal
Joe Paterno head at now need an uncovered yet.
Well,
I mean,
well you know,
but the,
the fucking uh,
I actually
did stand up for both teams down at the Improv.
They had like,
there's three things.
So one night they had us,
one day they'd USC,
one day they had Penn state.
Joe Paterno was not there.
I often wondered was sent Dusky there.
I mean,
granted everybody there was like the staff by then,
but everybody was shaving so he would,
he would have been hanging around.
They got to another rose bowl after what all that has happened right down a
little bit.
Do you think that they would ever,
Penn state would ever go to an improv comedy show like that now,
even if,
you know,
just some guy that might just think they would,
they're already on TV.
And yesterday I caught myself going,
oh,
let's see how they rebuild this.
And then I had to think,
wait and rebuild it from the pedophile case,
but they were already like,
they're bringing Joe Paterno statue back out.
And uh,
you know,
they took it down like he was fucking Sadam Hussein.
But I mean,
dude,
I don't want to get into that whole subject cause I love the guy,
but I just don't know.
No matter what generation,
no matter how old you are,
how you like,
you know what it is,
dude,
it's power.
It's money.
It's the reputation.
There was so much shit on the line that they tried to fucking and a handle it.
And I don't know,
handling in house,
who knows?
Let's not even talk about that.
So smoking,
so they,
uh,
so that first year,
um,
I don't even think we had cigars.
We might've had cigars,
but dude,
we got absolutely fucking annihilated.
I think all we had was the stakes or maybe burgers.
I can't,
I can't fucking remember all I remember dude,
I was selling cars.
You gotta understand when you guys go there,
like you help with the drinking with partner.
I would go in like one on one.
Like if partner was a wrestler,
we'd have to all come running in from the locker room.
Tried to take them down.
But I was
mud wrestling scene from strikes when everybody,
all the girls had to go pick down John.
Yeah.
Is shut out of a mom.
Um,
I actually saw that that actor who played,
uh,
we played psycho and brands is Sawyer,
right?
Yeah.
I saw him in an episode of Tj Hooker.
It,
Tj Hooker,
some of the worst acting ever,
ever.
And he's still great.
He still great in it.
He was just,
he just was a fucking,
yeah.
Great.
Atkins mammoth,
is that what his name was?
No,
no.
The other guy,
his partner hookers partner to good looking guy.
The young guy who played in Italian,
but he was,
uh,
he was,
our meaning our eastern block and he played,
he played Romano was his name,
his last name started with a z.
He wasn't Italian.
Yeah,
his real last name as like a Z,
y,
m t.
And it was like,
uh,
well you asked
to watch it because they,
they never call him TJ.
They just call them hooker the whole time so that they'll be like,
when Tj is in a difficult situation,
there'll be trying to find them out and the in and they got the walkie talkie
going,
hooker,
hooker and it's just like that.
I heard hooker from the day I was bored.
So like why,
how the fuck did they get on the air?
Like why wouldn't you just pick something else?
And that's probably why they just threw the Tj in the title so they could just
have the Tj but knew that they were going to have used it.
Yeah.
I don't think you're going to get away with like hooker Friday night hooker and
cvs,
CBS,
everybody.
Although that was right.
Everybody will know what I'm saying.
The characters could have said fucking a could have said it said like Tj,
right?
Tj.
That's still bad.
It is bad.
Call Him Tommy.
Tommy Hooker.
Tom,
Tom Thomas.
He needs,
he needs more of a manly man.
Built this program to what it is today.
I mean,
this is like now listen for your arrest from where it started to now we're
smoking meat.
Oh,
I,
the day starts with the Omelet got starts with the heater.
Who's getting the heat?
Yeah,
it starts off with a whiskey.
Then you have a fucking hundred of these.
Joe Barton.
Nick,
I could drink a hundred of these.
I love when he does that.
Literally Joe Part Nick,
after his first sip of Whiskey,
when it hits his lips,
he looks around everybody in this like strong whispery voice.
I could drink a hundred of these and then the nights,
the days on it,
he loses his ticket and then waits for us at the game.
Oh,
I don't even know if I even brought that up from last year.
That was the worst fucking,
that was like the Willem defoe moment and platoon left and by,
and somehow he lost his ticket.
We got,
yes,
so big.
He put him in his back pocket and I think,
cause I walk to the stadium with him,
you guys were a little ahead of us because he was moving slow.
You know,
Joe's a big duty at about a hundred of these in them.
Right.
And as I was kind of like stay in his pace,
like helping him and then we get to the gate and he goes right to his back
pocket and it's gone.
And I'm like,
I looked up at,
I'm like,
ah,
we walked around.
But it was one of those things like if somebody had their game on and they saw
that thing sticking out of his back pocket,
if he's just what you could just,
I mean those crowds,
you swipe it and you're gone.
Or if it just fell on the ground,
pick it up.
He go scalpels.
Sizewell yeah.
So he had to,
he had to stay outside.
That was a fucking worst.
Uh,
hey,
is it true that they don't sell booze at the Rodeo booze at Rose Bowl?
That's where
we are.
We're so in the,
I never noticed by then that we don't even care and I never noticed that they
don't.
So I gotta do,
I gotta do a couple of advertising right here.
If you just tuned again,
I like to say that like I,
this is actual radio station for then people downloaded it.
We're talking to the two of the temp Rosebowl tailgate legends.
Uh,
Jason Law head.
He's over here smoking a fucking pig's ass.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
dollar shave club,
everybody.
There is so many things in this world that irritate me.
People with neck pillows,
people ride bicycles and don't get over and feel like I have to drive the
slowest them because they want to go out on a ride.
Uh,
my own cowardice,
that annoys me.
Uh,
when so many things can irritate you,
why add raises to that list?
It's time to stop milking your razor blade.
Everybody.
I know what the brand name razors are used to paying outrageous prices and
exhausting those razors until they start to look like a rusty soda camp.
Well,
listen,
it's time to move on.
Goddammit.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing quality blades to your door just for a few
bucks a month.
Never think about it again.
They send a pack,
uh,
every month.
Why don't they ever have month in the damn copy?
He says they send the send a pack every so you can change your blades every
week.
Um,
they send a pack every month.
All right.
Uh,
I love these guys and your face will love them too.
They also have a new product called one wipe Charlies.
Jay,
I swear to God,
I refuse to believe this is real.
It's a buttwipe for men.
Come on and it's classy.
It's classy.
How can it wait,
wait,
wait.
He goes,
check out the video for that and sign up for your razors today.
He's like,
you,
you know what it is like the Columbia House.
Now this,
this is is like now they're great dude.
This is like a,
this is like the poor man's Butt Day.
You know,
you can't afford the spray of water,
but it's classy.
It's Classy,
which means it's a nice thickness.
So when you wipe it,
it's not going to tear and make your fingers all shitty over there.
A Go to dollar shave club.com forward slash birth,
that's dollar shave club.com forward slash four or go to [inaudible] dot com and
click on the dollar shave club banner eight the lady and your life's going to
love you.
If you can have a nice clean shave and a,
you're going to have a clean bottom.
Your frigging animals.
All right,
Hulu plus,
I'm sure you've tried hulu.com if you haven't,
you're a loser and I want you to know that came from my heart,
but I want to tell you about Hulu Plus who plus lets you watch thousands of hit
shows anytime,
anywhere,
streaming on your TV or go with your smartphone or tablet.
Um,
why stand in line or a re a ride a train and just stare at your feet.
You could be watching your favorite shows on Hulu plus or hitting on the hot
chick standing next year,
but whatever floats your boat,
who the plus is a great way to binge watch your favorite shows.
Hulu plus has tons of episodes from great comedies like SNL community,
modern family,
South Park,
family guy,
and thousands of other shows.
Hulu plus it's only seven 99 a month.
You cheap bastards,
seven 99 all for all the shows and movies you can watch catch up on current
shows,
a binge on old favorite favorites or catch a great movie.
You can do it all on Hulu plus right now.
You can try Hulu plus for a couple of weeks free on me when you go to the
podcast page bill bird.com and click on the Hulu plus banner or go to Hulu
plus.com/bill that's as easy as it can get me.
Please make sure you use Hulu plus.com so you can get an extended free trial and
so they know that we sent you all right,
makes me a little bit of cash.
Sheesh and it makes your viewing pleasures go through the roof,
I guess.
Is that what I'm trying to say?
All right,
now went back to the podcast here.
Everybody,
uh,
you're like,
you turned into like the Paul Harvey of
casters now,
you didn't make live spots like right in the middle,
you know,
like Paul Harvey now it's actually are,
Sharman tissue paper,
Charmin tissue.
And then he'd go right there.
Now the rest of the story,
Sherwin tissue wrap a Jap in it and light them on fire.
It's 1945.
Um,
yeah.
Back then when they would do like the,
the promos for the war,
I was watching all this emphasis of it reading these worlds war tube,
uh,
books and stuff and just watching some of those,
those like,
uh,
propaganda films that they have like dude,
like the,
the um,
the work,
they would actually show like literally like war crimes,
like strafing I guess was considered a war crime,
which is basically,
if you had people like defenseless in the water after you shut down this ship or
whatever,
shut down the ship,
torpedo their ship.
They would just see the survivors and the warrant.
Right.
And it would show that
no,
it to us,
it was brutal.
It was war man.
It's fucking brutal.
But what kills me is you think they try to keep it quiet,
but they were describing one showing strafing in,
in a movie theater.
The crowd was going nuts and it goes there.
They,
I boys let them have it and then he goes
deserve it.
It's like Phil,
I was like,
I'm Phil Hartman sketch
and it got to like,
they always did the music behind it too.
Like the time,
like the happy like parade music.
Oh yeah,
absolutely.
No,
I was
of repeating myself from last week.
Like both sides viewed each other like they were animals.
Like they thought that we,
we bled green blood and we had tails.
And uh,
I dunno where we said does,
we probably both said they,
each side was the devils.
They said,
you know,
if the Americans come kill yourself because they're going to eat you and all
this type of stuff.
And they were actually,
uh,
committing acts of cannibalism.
Dude,
I've read that this book fly boys.
I'm telling you this,
a chapter in there,
like I had to set it down and walk away for a little bit and then plow my,
cause it was such a good book.
Just that,
that one chapter on that they would,
it was a,
I don't know what's a,
were smoking a pork shoulder.
I don't need to be talking about,
yeah,
the sugar pork shoulder.
We're going to be making some Coleslaw.
Coleslaw.
Yeah,
but I don't need to be talking about fucking cannibalism.
If you had to,
if you had to eat a person.
All right Jay,
I gotta ask you this.
What's the body type you would be looking for?
You
wouldn't want survival or enjoyment.
Like if I had to like string it out over like if I had to like stock my shelf.
Well let's,
if I just really wanted an ice put on a nice suit and Hannibal Lecter,
I want you to be,
let's consider for a second that I'm surprised that,
that that reaction,
but let's just say your one night out or is it,
I'm a Hannah and island John Goodman.
If I'm,
you know what I mean?
Like,
yeah.
Okay.
John Goodman will be nice and marbled.
Yep.
It's a lot of flavor of that.
You've got an athlete,
it's gonna be yeah.
Too tough.
Exactly.
You know?
Right.
That's why,
that's why I asked and then can give,
you got to get it,
you know what you're the best one you got,
you got to get that married guy who used to work out,
but now he's got four kids.
I figured that would be the Volta that would be the best eats.
He's like Nice,
nice middle of the road kind of a guy.
Yeah.
And he used to dance.
Be Soft in areas where you can taste really good.
Like is no,
you think like,
I'm like now it was like his nose or his double Chin would taste really good.
Like I'd be like a snacks too exotic.
I ate like the pig hook up.
No pig cheek.
I at one time started like sweating up.
My body was just like,
what kind of fucking meat is this?
No,
you gotta you gotta go with the nightmares for like a month straight.
You got to go with the term volt is pork shoulder.
All right,
let's see.
Okay,
let's go with this Phillip Seymour Hoffman or uh,
or John Travolta.
I taught John Travolta be more like an eight ounce steak to be self fucking.
And I think Phillip Seymour Hoffman.
You'd have to check this.
You have to do a lot of cleaning.
Like you'd have to clean
it looks like he waxes so you wouldn't have to go off that.
You wouldn't have to like,
you know,
job so much of the hair off.
If I get killed a bear deer,
you have to really work the barrel.
Thank you.
Right now it was Louie Depalma.
Let's get out of this.
Yeah,
you're a big college football fan.
What'd you watch this weekend?
Obviously I was in Vegas this weekend.
I watch my buckeyes.
We didn't look great,
but uh,
I've got some work to do on defense number two in the country.
Oh,
I can't wait.
We might be seeing them,
uh,
get yourself out of the hole real quick.
Like that guy in the Viagra commercial when he hopes to truck up to the horse.
Right.
Well,
we got herb,
man,
urban Meyer.
That guy goes everywhere.
That guy goes,
he wins.
I mean,
this is winning percentage is ridiculous.
Like eight 70.
I mean,
he's undefeated season it Utah One.
I'm not as deep as,
you know,
he,
he's not the guy who was there when they got suspended,
he left dress was gone.
The white haired guy that's trestles guard.
We had the defensive coordinator was like an an an an an him for one year.
Uh,
thank God Meyer got sick of his family after a couple of years.
He,
oh,
I would spend time with my family now.
Luckily they were annoying and he's back on the scene
and,
uh,
two national titles.
He probably could have won one in Utah if it was before it was po,
Po prior bcs.
You know,
Alex Smith,
he recruited Alex Smith.
Uh,
you know,
getting rid of the bcs.
Like this is the last year.
They're going to go to the big,
they're going to go to that final four type thing.
They're going go to a finally
like,
has somewhat of a play off.
You got to play two games.
Yeah.
You're going to do.
They have a final for an NCAA football final four.
Huge.
That's ridiculous.
And you know it,
most of the Games will be played right here in our backyard right here.
I mean there'd be idiots not to use Pasadena for that.
That's going to be amazing.
Well,
I've got to tell you,
I watched my Lsu tigers playing the uh,
he go brown.
Hey.
You know what's funny is I,
I couldn't find the fucking game cause I kept looking up Lsu when it's on.
All he saw was versus Texas Christian University and I'm so dumb.
I didn't,
I didn't know what they all,
they never said it the whole game.
They didn't go,
come on Texas Christian University,
they want to take no problems.
That was the game.
We saw them against Wisconsin.
That was the game when we basically knew then we had to up our game in the tail
gate realm.
It was that Tcu is causing game.
Like was that too next to us?
Had the flat screen TV.
That's when we were like,
dude,
what are we doing?
We thought we had,
we thought we came owed more prepared from the year before,
which was right.
And then we were like last year,
last year where the first time we had people were looking at our tailgate,
go and see those guys.
They're doing it right.
People were coming over every time I lift it up on the big one is women.
When women start looking over gone,
thank God.
Look,
because women don't forget anything.
No.
Yeah,
we had like moms like Wisconsin,
mom's coming over going,
what are you cooking?
Like wherever,
you know,
what is that were like kind of like trying to be nice to us to see if we'd offer
them someone.
It was done like get them like,
oh yeah,
it was great.
I guess the greatest singer,
but la,
I watched the,
the Ellis Lsu Tcu game and I gotta tell you,
man,
this is supposed to be a rebuilding year for us.
This is my team,
but I got to tell you a Boston,
well do,
what am I?
What am I gonna Route?
You got that football program that gone and a BC.
I never was a,
I liked their hockey,
but I just was never into the football team.
I just was never ended.
I never liked the uniforms.
Well,
yeah.
And you said that Maroon with the gold.
I just never got like once every 10 years.
Every DePaul they did an amazing job.
We had some great coaches.
Said the fucking Guy Guy there with the,
uh,
the,
the rosacea on his face from the wind burn.
Oh,
time.
Coplin yeah,
we had him when it's not in season,
I can't remember anybody's fucking name.
But anyways,
we got that met and Burger guy at quarterback and now they're not switching off.
He actually looked really fucking solid.
They got cam Cameron now and is the a QB coach to everywhere.
That guy look on waivers.
Drew Brees and uh,
what's his face?
Joe Flacco when the Superbowl last year,
he coached all of those guys.
So I feel good about that.
They got to,
they got this new kid.
Ego.
Ferguson is great,
isn't it?
Sec?
What Games are the best right name?
Anthony Johnson.
Both those guys were beasts yesterday.
Um,
and then they've seen that,
you know,
the receivers are right,
Odell Beckham's.
All right.
That's going to be a good year in a sec.
Cause I mean obviously less what we're doing here.
We're doing Spurrier ball.
If LSU did didn't,
didn't have that one,
that one fumble,
that blue kid,
I don't know whose fault it was,
but dropped it right there and just basically gave him seven points.
Uh,
but Tcu actually looks strong and they're fucking uniforms.
A great,
yeah,
it was black on.
Did you hear what was blue?
Why they had that?
Uh,
no,
it's purple with the purple.
Black and purple.
Yeah.
But why they had the uh,
that Red Stripe?
No,
because I guess when the Horn toad or whatever the fuck it is,
the horn frog,
when it gets mad and it gets upset,
blood comes out of its eyes.
Yeah.
So that's what that's supposed to be.
We got to see one,
I got to see one of those real life.
I've never seen me in real life and aids.
Who's,
or do they exist?
They do well,
how you do this sign that they have is,
it's the Fred Sanford Yard.
I got the Os right hands.
I can't work.
I can't pick it up.
Hey,
do you need to check on that shoulder?
Yeah.
And they'd come back.
So anyways,
yeah.
So I am a,
I am not referring to Lsu is,
is my team as a just,
I dunno,
I just did that acting gig down there and I got to tell you,
I actually Miss New Orleans,
New Orleans sour.
The fuck you say it.
I,
I was there long enough to see the regular people where they live in those
fucking awesome houses.
I got to tell you the humidity is for the fucking birds.
Um,
but I dunno,
I really liked it and I actually was getting into the saints was just a fun town
party town.
People like to booze.
I like to booze people like sports.
I like sports.
You know,
the only thing was missing was a fucking hockey team.
And then I liked the fact that they named that team the Pelicans and everyone
was giving him shit,
including me.
And they were starting to fucking bond over the fact that nobody liked their
name.
And uh,
I dunno,
I spent too much time down there and I fell in love with the fucking city.
Go ahead,
sue me.
So when law heads comes back,
we're going to talk about our upcoming trip out to Denver.
Uh,
what am I going to talk about now?
Is it time to get into the questions?
Oh,
fuck.
37 minutes in.
Let's get into the questions for this week.
Everybody,
uh,
Syria,
General Billy Patton.
Here's what's going on in Syria.
I love that he starts with that.
Other than other words,
I kind of fucked up.
What?
Ha,
well,
whatever I said was going on last week.
So here's the real deal.
I guess Assad is killing his people now.
That's the,
uh,
the Grand Poobah who's in charge over there.
He's killing his people.
Not all of his people.
Just the people that don't like him and anybody who's standing nearer,
I think anyways,
equally terrible rebels,
some of whom are al Qaeda,
al Qaeda are now going to be supported by the u s military.
Now you're probably wondering,
well why would we support anything that alcaide is doing?
Cause there it's,
it's a money thing.
I guess this is sad isn't doing what we want them to do.
So,
uh,
we're going to try and support the fucking,
the Marlins,
right.
That works to the Marlins sucked this year.
I have no idea.
Anyway,
estimated up to 1.5 million civilians have been displaced.
That means homeless.
I guess so now going to bomb Syria but also target some of Russia's shit and see
in Syria.
Yeah.
Cause they're supporting the Assad guy.
What's my call?
Well I gotta tell Ya,
Russia is the six and nine team that nobody wants to play.
I mean a lot of fucked it.
Why now?
I don't know what's going on over there.
Okay.
I don't know who's I look,
I know that the only reason why we're over there was because of fucking money
and something that comes out of the ground.
Other than that,
we don't give a fuck.
All right.
We don't,
we didn't give a shit about the people in New Orleans.
Why would we give a shit about them over there?
It's all about fucking,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't know.
And whether that is the proper way to do it or if that's an evil way of doing
what goes on around the world,
I have no idea because I've never sat in a meeting in the Pentagon,
so I have no idea what's going to go on over there.
I feel bad for all the innocent people sitting there in the crossfire.
And I feel lucky that I can lay in a bed and do a podcast right now.
Need some fucking poor pig's ass.
That's all I got for you,
sir.
What's my call?
Um,
yeah.
Well,
it's an uphill battle,
I'd have to say.
I mean,
it's a home game for his side and now that they brought in the Russians,
well,
they don't have the greatest record.
They will.
He beat the fucking Germans.
That was great.
They just backed into their own country and just burned and blew up dams and
bridges and all that.
Shay fucking raped their own goddamn country.
So the Russians would have nothing the fuck they drew them in and then the
winter came and then that was it.
They did the old rope,
a dope before fucking alley.
So he got to give them that one then,
but then they lost in Afghanistan.
That's always a hard thing to,
when you,
when you got a road game in the game of war,
that's such a fucking hard one to win because,
uh,
the occupy in game,
because they know eventually you're gonna fucking leave,
right?
Eventually.
You know,
your soldiers are going to want to go home,
right.
Sit down and have a fucking sandwich.
They get an egg.
I Dunno,
find love and get on with their fucking life.
So that's,
I dunno,
Afghanistan,
that's a tough one,
man.
You know what they are,
they like the charges in the first round of the playoffs.
It's just a very,
very dangerous team.
Um,
so what's my call?
I think it's going to cost billions of dollars.
It's going to make a couple of people $1 billion.
Then everybody else is just going to be suffering.
That's what I think is going to happen.
And it's probably gonna ruin some of the environment.
That's what I,
that's my call more of the same surf and it's just going to breed more hatred
and it's not going to solve anything.
That's what I think.
All right.
Onward and upward towards new levels of misery.
Grass fed steak.
A dare bill bunches.
You talked about juicing and all that.
Have you to grass fed steak switched to what?
I've been eating it the whole fucking time.
I do two juices a day and then I throw down for dinner.
Right.
I eat like a yoga instructor for the first two fucking meals and then I eat like
John Wayne.
So what's better than doing it three times a day?
Um,
anyways,
he said it's amazing.
It tastes like steak.
Tasted like 1520 years ago before they started pumping the cows full of
everything.
Well,
I think they've been doing it longer than that.
Having that,
there's a company called grass fed beef company that Rogan talked about and had
the owner on his podcast.
I highly ranked commend.
Uh,
I'll cut.
Cool.
I highly recommend the Joe Rogan experience podcast because it's the exact
opposite of this one where I just say shit with no facts behind it.
Borderline makeup stuff.
Um,
he actually,
uh,
oh shitty.
You got a TV show on about Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
So,
um,
this is like,
I do,
what I do on this podcast is kind of like,
you know,
when you had what you thought was a cool teacher and then years later you
realized he was completely irresponsible and wasn't doing his job slash may be
trying to fuck one of the students.
That's what I do here.
What Rogan does,
Rogan actually teaches the class.
He earns his paycheck.
All right,
there you go.
I probably just lost some fucking listeners,
but you know what,
every once in a while even I have to tell the truth,
you know,
uh,
back to school.
Mr. Barr,
do you miss going back to school?
I missed the social aspects of it.
I miss if I could have appreciated going like going back to school,
especially if you're in like a public school that's like going to a club with no
cover charge and every woman and is in there is single and is in their prime.
Yeah.
You know as are you all the guys have full heads of hair,
right?
All the ladies get their looking good.
I made just to fucking shooting fish in a barrel.
You don't need no opening lines or anything.
What's your side?
But,
but you know you've been going to school for fucking ever now you got to do a,
you know,
just shoot the shit with them.
I wish I knew that.
I did not know that.
Hence that was a complete failure,
failure and that department.
Anyways,
he goes,
I'm 31 and every year around this time I think about how fun it was to go back
to school despite the fact that I hated summer ending.
It didn't want to be in class.
You knew you didn't have a choice and focused on the good things like which
girls are going to come back hot.
Will it be a new hot girl in school?
I'm glad I get to see the girl I had a crush on last year but didn't see all
summer because I was a nerd and had no balls.
What do you miss?
Yeah,
I miss all of that.
I miss running into my friends cause back before you even had a car,
like you wouldn't see even most of your friends all summer.
Um,
yeah I missed out on a lot of shit.
It's like when star wars came up and we didn't have,
you know,
we only had three channels and we didn't have the ones that the kids watched the
UHF
stations.
And I guess that that's where they advertise that I dunno,
we will live in a bubble.
I went outside everyday,
played in the woods,
played sports,
went swimming.
I completely missed out when star wars came out,
came out.
And uh,
when I got back to school in September,
everybody was talking about it and I had no idea what anybody was talking about.
And I just had to kind of like a,
just stand there and then people realized that I wasn't contributing.
You know,
I felt like Steve Carell and fucking 40 year old virgin when he's talking about
filling up a girl saying it feels yeah,
like a bag of sand.
You know,
when he said that,
like that's what I,
I had nothing.
And um,
so finally somebody asked me,
they're like,
you know,
Bill,
did you see star wars?
And I was like,
uh,
no.
Actually I didn't.
And then all the little,
oh my God,
you need to see what a fucking loser.
Yeah,
no.
And that was it.
And I got trashed.
I literally get trashed for the rest of recess.
Recess.
What's wrong with your parents?
And Blah,
blah,
blah.
And I just wished,
like that's one of the things I wish I could go back to certain parts.
Um,
J law,
heads back everybody.
Okay,
buddy.
We're talking about,
uh,
going back to school here.
And by we,
I mean me and my listeners who aren't talking,
um,
and just saying things that you missed,
are there any moments that you wish you could go back to in school to just have
that fucking comeback?
You know when somebody gave you shit and maybe beat the shit out of somebody or
maybe fucking ask the girl out the regrets anything.
Hmm.
That's a good question.
You know what I,
one big regret I have is that uh,
my parents always had one of them always took me to school.
That was so cool.
So,
so what to what gives?
My parents were all the way.
My Dad was my highest,
my senior government teacher.
Oh my.
I rolled into the high school at my,
I rolled into high school with my dad every day.
Oh Jesus.
But there must've been some girls.
It's cute.
They did cause my dad,
every,
all the girls thought my dad,
they like,
there was a couple of girls that had shrines and my dad,
he was kind of a good looking guy for his age back then.
He had the power,
you know how the guys,
when you had the power of dad by the way,
is a hall of Fame High School Basketball coach.
Great Guy.
You met him but he,
he,
so he had that bond believable.
But he was also a sharp looking guy.
He was a good dresser.
He's kind of like a Pat Riley,
Chuck Daley of his era.
He was always a sharp dresser.
Um,
good head of hair.
So there was a one girl in my class,
I won't name her because if she's listening,
she's just,
yeah,
don't ever don't name names.
No.
But she had,
like,
I,
I discovered this my junior year,
she had a shrine to my dad because he was the coach.
So there would be newspaper articles or anything she cut out of like our school
paper.
She'll open her locker one day and there was a show like pictures of him from
the newspaper,
pictures of him coaching pictures of him from the thing.
And she was like,
what did you seriously just like,
it was creepy,
you know,
I'm Kinda half him.
Yeah.
That's gotta be where the hand job and about of him.
I'm a,
I'm
a,
I'm a seventh of him,
I hope,
but I'm like you.
So it was just kind of creepy.
But I think the one thing is I was held back in the fifth grade.
This is like kind of a joke I tell.
Um,
trouble maker,
but the thing was is like a little bit of like a trouble maker,
not doing my work,
getting in with the wrong crowd type thing.
But the joke was is no,
no,
no.
I was just like,
you know,
like uh,
getting sent to the office,
allied being,
you know,
sent in the corner.
I was,
Shit's great.
I mean,
I wasn't doing drugs.
I got held back in first grade,
but not because of me.
My,
my brother was gonna borderline get held back in third grade and then my dad,
what you catching them and no,
my dad just had this one for all,
all for one kind of thing.
So we held everybody back and then just felt like boys are more,
aren't as mature as girls,
they should be held back.
So we held all of his pack.
Yeah,
that's part of why I was like the maturity level of just being a,
as a young youngster.
And you know what's funny is I still completely fucking screwed up in,
in high school.
I actually went back to my parents' house a few years ago and you know,
I was getting the last remaining shit out of there and my mother doesn't throw
anything out.
And she had some of my,
my report cards too.
I make just,
it was fucking ridiculous.
It was cs ds and we didn't have F's.
They were called ease.
And I don't know why I'd see those.
Like cs ds,
like the high water mark maybe was a solid c and it was just deep plus d minus d
e and you're a smart guy.
You're a smart guy.
I mean,
that's like interesting.
Like,
no,
you're a smart guy.
I mean you're a genius be you're a smart guy.
And uh,
from what I know,
I know what I'm good at and what I'm good at is being a loud mouth fucking idiot
and somehow thanks to this business,
I'm able to turn that into a living.
But if I was in anything else.
Um,
I always,
always a good,
I got a good work ethic from my parents,
but I,
I trust me dude.
I failed at a lot of shit.
A lot of shit.
Yeah.
I just,
I just wanted to have fun,
dude.
That's all I want to do.
I didn't want to lie.
I didn't want to a,
I didn't want to work.
I,
I didn't mind working,
but it had to be fun.
That's why I liked working at warehouses.
I'd like blue collar jobs because there was this thing where you were working
but you weren't in like this office of this cubicle.
You weren't in this designated area.
It's switched yet different job sites and everybody was fucking funny.
Like I had a buddy of mine,
he did construction and um,
I went over to his job site one time and dude,
they were the funniest motherfuckers and they had like catch phrases.
He had this thing where they would do,
if anybody bitched,
they would just like someone be like,
you know what the fuck is my nail gun?
I Blah Blah.
And you hit somebody on the other side of house,
just go
through like this baby thing,
they this whack thing and that's who they would get because what they were doing
was this unbelievable.
It was a fucking bitch of a job.
So what it is,
you just saw how humor worked because if he starts bitching everybody bitches,
then you just doing this job and he got this negative thing.
So it was this way to see because anybody would do it and they would start
fucking laugh.
Everybody else would start fucking laughing.
You'd be 90 degree heat,
putting a fucking roof on a house,
just hating your life.
Did I remember one time I lasted,
I lasted 10 days doing this shit before I went back to the warehouses.
I was fucking uh,
working with these guys and we were putting a roof on something and I know I had
to put like the scaffolding,
like the supports up,
drilling holes in and fucking,
you know,
hanging on the side of the house so they can put the board across it so they
could do the fucking the roof.
And I remember next door was his house with a backyard with an in ground pool
and these two fucking hot chicks are bringing out shit and as these two guys
fucking Jersey shore looking guys laying out right and enjoy in their fucking
summer.
And I was just sitting there going like,
what the fuck is wrong with this picture?
I remember one of them,
one point was looking up,
watching us work and like he was just one of those good looking shredded guys.
So he didn't have a fucking ounce of guilt,
not announced where I would actually in shame gone back into the house.
Like I don't want to be enjoying the pool with those guys working like that.
They,
this guy was just fucking like,
if you would've felt radio louder,
you would have felt like we were making the roof for him.
He just fucking owned it.
And I'll tell you that guy,
he has no regrets from his childhood.
He crushed I,
you just see it.
This guy's crushing everything he was.
This is fucking beautiful.
God,
that's funny.
I still remember that.
And there was this Irish guy,
Billy,
it must work quicker.
You must work quicker.
And at one point I got mad.
I was like,
dude,
this is the first time I fucking never put these up.
If you want me to go faster and you've landed on your fucking back,
I'll do it.
You know?
Wow.
That's like
I never had a real job.
That's what I,
the one thing I've loved about my life so far is I've never had one of those
jobs where you just hate every day.
Like,
you know,
going into,
I've always worked in the restaurants or you know,
hard like hard labor,
worked out on the highway crew,
worked a little construction,
the more of a labor.
I didn't know how to build anything right Kerry in the ship.
But those kind of guys,
you're right.
Those kind of jobs are where you meet really funny people that you know
appreciate the things that,
that they get when they get them because they're working their ass off.
You know,
one time we had a guy who worked in the guy was a total fucking alcoholic,
like coke head maniac.
And one time he showed up,
like,
I swear to God,
like he was supposed to be the eight 30,
showed up like 10 30,
10,
45.
And he comes in all bleary died and,
and his fucking hair there
was soaking wet from a shower.
And he just comes walking in and he goes,
oh,
the traffic's traffic was doing,
his fucking hair was soaking wet.
Dude,
his eyes look like roadmaps,
right?
He's big.
Like,
it was funny,
he had like this,
he was a big guy,
but he never worked out.
It was just all calories from his awful life.
And he had this limp fish handshake.
He had skinny arms,
skinny legs,
and just this keg of a chest,
you know?
And even when those guys just keeps pushing the pants down and tightness and
Belcher,
so he fucking,
um,
so we just used to keep giving him shit.
This is before like being an alcoholic,
considered like a sad disease.
So remember what we were going to get donuts that day and fucking hilarious.
Who Go,
Hey,
you know,
Paul,
I can't say I just said his name.
you don't want,
you want a,
you want anything for donkeys?
We're going to Dunkin donuts.
You want anything you want to,
you know,
but back then they had muffins,
they had donuts and that type of shit and he gives you guys right that and
somebody goes,
how about a donut?
No good muffin.
I've good copy and I'm good.
And then this other guy goes,
how about a rum cake?
We all fucking laughed our asses off of the guy.
Long story short,
he finally,
he ends up getting fired and he left one of his,
remember the show,
Remember Shaq?
It's,
it was like a,
it was a jacket and a shirt.
It was basically like a flannel shirt with like a,
yes,
it had the,
yeah,
Shaq it.
So he left that thing behind and this one dude you talking about like a funny
basket and I'm like,
but really like artistic.
He took all these empty boxes and made like a giant statue of the guy out of the
boxes and he put the jacket on it and he drew these bleary eyes and he put like
this mop and thing on top too.
We fucking came in.
Even the boss,
we were fucking howling at this drunk that we didn't even try to help.
We just fired,
fired.
The guy sent him out on the street and then we just made that.
We laughed our asses off when we leave and we left it up for like fucking like
look,
this shrine.
It was up for like two weeks and then finally the boss was just so well run low
on boss.
You got to fucking take that thing down.
Do we had this other guy?
I feel bad about this one.
This guy we hired this guy in and the boss thought it would be a good idea to
hire somebody that was a little bit older to try to get some sort of fucking
maturity because do we want,
we will.
We just did all this dumb shit like uh,
you didn't care about your job.
It is did dumb shit.
And then we,
and we had like these things that we would do to get through the day.
I remember there was this guy,
hey,
what bid is this thing in?
And it was,
it was seven 37 and he kept going seven 37 in the gag.
Why?
And he finally jumped off these boxes and did like this karate thing
is loud as he could.
And then one day we just decided we were all going to scream that at the same
time.
And the door was open from the warehouse into the suited area where everyone was
dressed like Michael J.
Fox and out of nowhere and every,
it was just really quiet.
Summer Day,
the entire warehouse screamed at the top of their lungs,
just went
right and I'm around it,
I can pick this.
So still,
I didn't know why we did it.
Picked his fucking head up and his boss immediately came running in and he's
going,
they're yelling that they're yelling out here like,
like we were animals.
Like what are they doing?
And then he got fucking,
I almost said balled out.
This is how old this story is.
Remember that expression,
all that yelled at and then he came out and he had this high pitched voice and
Ebook,
you know,
come on you guys,
you all here with Blah Blah Blah.
And then whenever he would talk we would just just do this impression of him
back.
We wouldn't even listen.
We were just
then you would just be frustrated and would walk away shaking his head and would
just be like a bunch of babies.
Just a bunch of babies and we would,
we wouldn't listen to any anybody like the level of mad that he had to get cause
he oh that's right cause he gives us a substitute teacher.
He used to be us and then he got promoted.
Ah,
there you go.
That's what it was like.
I've asked from wondered how Bill Russell was able to coaches players even
though they all one together and he was the legend.
He had,
you know,
nine rings at that point,
10 rings before he got his 11th like there's just something about like,
dude,
you're telling me to run the stairs now.
Give me a fucking break.
Exactly that.
That's where,
yeah,
come on.
All right,
let me,
uh,
I got to read one more advertising here.
My little more Paul Harvey thing here and then I got to go a good day.
Good day.
What have we got here?
Is this it?
Uh,
or we got a couple of here.
All Right,
ladies and gentlemen,
uh,
he voice.
If you're an entrepreneur and a customer calls,
do you want to seem like you're in a high rise window view,
fancy pants offers or do you want them to know you're sitting in your underwear
with he voice?
You can create the appearance of an entire building,
sales,
customer support,
tech support,
you name it.
They're going to think you've got a giant office.
Uh,
give your customers the royal treatment with he voice.
A voice will forward business calls to your home,
mobile or any number you choose.
Wherever you are,
he voice.
We'll find you don't have time to take a call.
No problem.
It's routed to your voicemail and you can read it at your convenience as an
email.
He voice not only gives you an edge over competitors,
it takes away the edge that big companies have over you right now.
Why?
Because you can appear that you're just as big as they are and now you can try
he voice for 30 days for free.
Go to [inaudible] dot com use the Promo Code Bill.
That's [inaudible] Dot Com Promo Code Bill B I l l or just go to the podcast
page for billboard.com and click on the voice banner.
Last but certainly not least legal zoom.
Everybody.
Most Americans do not have a will,
but why?
I don't know cause they don't have a pot to piss in.
That's why I don't have a will.
That's what I would guess.
But if you do,
if you just,
if you do have a pot and it is filled with Piss,
you don't want government rules dictating what happens to you,
to your property and your minor children.
A lot of people have children.
Here we go.
This is why.
So why procrastinate?
Most people say it's too expensive,
too.
Time consuming I or want to deal with my answer is legal,
zoom.com too expensive.
You're going to love legal zooms,
responsible prices,
too.
Time consuming.
I love these questions.
Most people finish the online process and just 20 minutes and we're not just
talking some fill in the blank form.
Your will is a state specific purse and personalized based on your information.
Best of all,
legal zoom has 12 years of experience helping people with important legal
matters.
Uh,
it's national make a will month.
Everybody,
every month is that gets us,
I've been saying this for three months.
Uh,
so don't wait any longer.
Go to legal zoom.com today and get 15% off last will,
but this offer ends soon or get Lee illegal trust and you'll receive a power
over will absolutely free.
Um,
to get your special discount.
Be sure to enter burden,
the referral box at checkout for wills,
powers of attorney and trust and more.
Go to legalzoom.com legalzoom can provide self help services that your specific
direction or connect you with the attorneys,
but they are not illegal love from there we go.
You know what?
I think I just read advertising from last month.
I like how they basically that that,
I mean,
I like,
I like how that basically,
like they say everything in a roundabout way of basically,
please don't trash my advertisers do it before you.
Oh wait,
wait.
They're basically saying do it before your dad wasn't supposed to read legal
zone that I messed up.
So they got a free one in there.
That's a day.
That's why I keep saying it's national.
Make a will month.
Yeah.
Who has really,
no,
I didn't.
Uh,
well,
there's always something like,
I don't know what time I was in Atlanta and it was,
it was national blueberry pancake day,
you know,
from the people who bring you blueberries comes blueberry pancake day.
It's just like,
it's like naming a star,
except there's only 365.
All right,
let's,
let's move on here.
Where are we in the podcast?
Oh,
by the way,
how's the,
uh,
she's looking good.
Did you peak?
Oh yeah,
I just peeked.
She's looking good.
There's a little look in you.
We're right at two 75.
Well,
I wanted to make sure that the chips were needed.
Any we got,
you know,
we're a,
we're adding,
you know,
bull soaked apple chips to this bad boy.
We're smoking them.
Oh,
what did you start with the apple?
You start with the APP?
Yeah.
Just sprinkle it with you to get some books.
I want it to smell back then.
We were back then it was some hickory.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't give me the cores light of smoke to fucking take,
but no.
Uh,
all right.
Need to stop being in nervous cunt.
This is going to be the last one here.
People,
uh,
Billy red face.
Love the podcast.
Oh,
speaking of red face,
the red state tour.
It got splintered because of the acting work.
So flinor this,
but though,
but I,
I make it up,
all of them.
So this week is going to be a boulder and pikes peak on Wednesday and Friday.
Thursday we have off dump,
dump dump.
I'm fine.
We're going,
we're going to the a Broncos,
a ravens game.
But what are you in Vegas this weekend?
He wanted me to ask you.
He goes,
cause you know when you're under the disguise,
I'm from Cleveland everybody originally if you haven't known that.
But the funny thing is when I told my boys this weekend I was going to the
Broncos ravens game.
They're like well look this is the guy not like you because you know the ravens
for the browns and the Broncos like put it in our heart like nine times.
But if it has nothing to do with that,
the actual Cleveland Brown franchise at this point.
You just hate the ravens.
Well because of the browns.
Yeah,
originally cause there's a brown shirt.
Gorgeous.
Yeah.
We still hate him because of that.
That's why we hate them and they're in our division and they,
they,
they've awesome new goes still ravens and win a super bowl twice.
It w w you know what I mean?
That does,
does,
does Ozzie Newsome still work for them?
That's the problem.
He's the only guy that went with and he's been running that team and he had just
gotten the job.
Like he,
he was an ex player.
He had just gotten the job as president of football operations when we were in
Cleveland.
They leave town.
He goes,
he,
they got to see,
do you know why you guys never get you?
I don't know if he would want the attention cause I lived through it.
It sucks.
You don't want to be like,
Oh this sports misery capitol of the world.
The reason why you guys don't get the attention is because you're not rivals
with New York City.
Right.
I think that that's why we got what we did because,
uh,
was Yankees red sox and then like,
well you know what it was.
We get a little bit of that because we're a Steeler rival.
While we're not assigning an,
we would considered a rival any more.
The Pittsburgh doesn't even worry about us,
but we,
we,
the brown specifically do kind of have that moniker and the NFL kind of realm
because of that Steeler rivalry and they won six.
But you know what's crazy is if you go back and count NFL championships and
bowls combined,
we still have more.
We have seven NFL James.
I think it's so ridiculous that they don't count NFL championships because the
green bay packers or the Yankees a football.
Oh yeah.
They've,
they've won in all areas.
They had a rough,
the 70s and eighties were rough for them.
All right.
When the Lynn Dickey,
yeah,
years.
But even then they had James lofty do.
At one point they had James Lofton and John Jefferson Grande.
They had nobody to throw the ball to one of the worst moves a player ever made.
John Jefferson said he went from the San Diego chargers Air Corre el would Dan
file,
Dan Fouts.
And he signed for more money to play in frozen fucking green bay.
It wasn't Lynn Dickey at that point.
I forget who it was.
What was the thought that was before the magic man?
Whoever the fuck they had in between there,
they just,
they just went through a bad period.
Yeah.
And,
um,
he said,
he said if I stayed in San Diego,
uh,
Jerry Rice would be breaking all my records and I'm telling you don't it wasn't
line.
No,
no doubt he was,
he was unreal.
Him and I remember West Chandler,
oh west Chandler,
Chandler in that strike here with the Redskins won it.
He fucking,
uh,
he still had over a thousand yards.
That's how much they were throwing it.
Really?
Those guys only played like 12 games,
didn't it?
Less than that dude.
They played like eight or nine.
Eight or nine that the,
the the,
I want to say the Redskins were like eight and won that year.
Yeah.
Cause the scrubs played like four of them.
Right.
Or to whatever they call them.
Oh,
is that that year that the scab scabs.
Yeah.
Yes.
Something that I find fascinating is just how like certain teams just,
they get new coaches,
they get new owners and blah,
blah blah.
But they just still,
there's this thing where they just like,
the giants will always just have a great defense.
The bear is always have a good defense,
but they can't for the life of them.
The bears have never had a superstar quarterback.
Everett,
even Jim Mcmahon.
Jim Mcmahon was a personality.
He was,
he was downtown Julie Brown of quarterbacks.
Right.
Like more like a social life.
Yeah.
I would put him,
he couldn't jump.
I know people couldn't carry you on his back and the fourth quarter,
like an la or a Montana.
He wasn't that kind of a,
they've never had that.
Cleveland Auto Graham maybe was your last superstar.
Bernie was tough.
Man.
[inaudible] was good.
But yeah,
really,
I mean,
we had a Frank Ryan,
a lot of people forget.
People Forget.
Frank rang.
Brian Sipe won an MVP in 81 almost wondered again in 82.
Um,
Frank Ryan was great.
Frank Ryan,
I believe site Rick Springfield.
Same Guy.
I'm telling you.
When I,
my head,
when I think of them per Frank Ryan though,
a lot of people don't realize,
I think Frank Ryan has the greatest winning percentage of any starting
quarterback in the history of the NFL.
He came after Otto Graham,
but he was winning Paul Brown.
They were still winning titles.
It's like just winning titles left and right all the time.
I believe had bill Bellacheck for one year.
Last time we won a playoff game.
The last time we won a game,
we beat the New England Patriots and Bill Belichick was our coach the last time
94 I was at that game,
wildcard game in Cleveland Stadium.
The last time we have won a playoff,
we'd be who do you like?
Who Do you like?
Uh,
what do you think?
Pate manning.
Wes Welker.
I love that match.
Why leave veterans and I think we're going to see if like a 45 38 or Thursday
night.
Yeah,
I think so.
Yeah.
I can Flaco they can put a dude,
bro.
Baltimore's going to put up some points this year.
They're going to have to,
cause at defense ain't going to be as good as it used to be.
We're gonna see a ball game.
Yeah,
but it's Flaco that good Flacko is that good?
You think you can put it in numbers like that?
I'm not saying he's not a good quarterback cause I think he's a,
he's a good quote.
I didn't believe in him forever and I was wrong.
That playoff run man.
I think that played out and showed it.
But is he like,
he's going to go fucking touchdown for touchdown against Manny?
Well maybe.
I mean maybe,
maybe not all season long,
but in this game,
you know what's funny about manning is like everybody was looking at like,
he was a little fragile China doll and now,
now that he made the season,
nobody's even thinking about it.
Like he keep one hit.
They was showing his spinal cord.
This guy could never walk again and now nobody's,
nobody's talking about it.
Some of them are predicting them doing the MVP award this year.
Longest neck since the program is another coach named Steve Grogan to deep
Grogan had to wear like two neck braces.
Just the pile them up.
Yeah.
Well they have,
they have all that flesh between the shoulder pads and the helmet.
You have like two or three of them on top of each other.
We'll see.
I think they're going to have,
they're going to,
oh,
this is my prediction on a,
uh,
Tim Tebow.
Tim Tebow is to get cut and he's going to go to the CFL is going to become a
superstar up there like Doug Flutie did and he's going to come back the end of
his career either with Buffalo,
with the bears.
Really?
That's my prediction.
He's going to the CFL.
CFL.
Yes sir.
You heard it here tonight?
Monday morning podcast.
Yeah.
He'll be able to and be able to run around because that feels like a hundred
yards in both directions.
Right?
Or meters,
whatever the fuck they say.
It's 110 long and I think 60 wide to see.
See what I'm saying?
Just when you guys thought I was a sports fan,
this is why I go to him.
He,
he fucking knows everything.
All right.
Need to stop being a nervous cut.
Billy red face loved the podcast.
Uh,
as soon as I have a need for any of the services that are advertising your show,
I'll make sure I go there was okay.
Thank you.
Um,
this may not rate Jesus.
Get to the fucking point.
I'm dying a slow death working a day job that isn't fun anymore.
The money's great.
I'm 32 and make a mid six figure salary,
but like you,
I'm not really motivated by more money.
I would much rather,
okay.
I dream on a daily basis.
He wrote that all in capital letters about doing comedy full time.
All right,
Jay,
this guy's making mid six figures.
He's 32 years.
You can have,
I got 45 minutes.
You can take it right now.
Give me the wool.
Mid Six figures.
I'm gone.
Uh,
standup,
Improv,
sketch,
performing,
writing,
producing.
I'd love to do it all.
I'd love to do it all all the time.
But the flip side of not being motivated by more money is being motivated by the
fear of not having enough.
See,
I'm a nervous condition as you would say.
I will do once you're making mid six figures in your 32 years old,
you're not nervous.
You're,
you're also kind of rational.
Okay.
You'd like,
that's why you try and start as young as you can because you stepping off a curb
rather than a fucking three story building at this point that you own and have
tenants in.
Um,
that is there till I was 31.
Yeah,
no,
no.
Absolutely.
And what's his face?
Retired,
um,
Dangerfield and he came back.
I'm not discouraging the guy.
I'm just saying that
not when I wasn't making six figures,
I don't think I would have just jumped off the curve for that.
Right,
right,
right.
He's,
look,
he,
he's,
he's not nervous.
That's what I'm saying.
He's thinking rationally.
So anyways,
he goes,
see I'm,
I'm a nervous cons as you would say with the New Jersey Mortgage,
Aka the land of high taxes bills and a three year old daughter.
I can't bring myself to cut and run from the corporate country.
I work in,
my wife and I have no debt other than the mortgage do.
That's great.
That's great man.
And we generally live below our income level.
That's also great.
Those are two things you need to do,
which people don't do any more than that.
Yeah,
you really need to do that,
man.
Uh,
but I don't think we live at or below the income that we'd have if I stop
killing myself on a daily basis by commuting to a fucking computer instead of
community to a couch with a laptop and a giant cup of coffee just to work on
comedy ship.
I love Shit.
I love how he's,
he's romanticizing being comedian.
Yeah.
Although he's kind of right.
Um,
it's more coming out of your pajamas with a hangover trying to figure out how to
get dealt with fucking whatever you picked up that night out of your hotel room
and then going downstairs and having a greasy breakfast to fucking,
I dunno.
Anyways,
I have no frame of reference to know how much money could be made or how long it
would take to make it.
And I'm scared shitless that I don't have the talent or the balls or both to
actually get paid to make people laugh in spite of believing in [inaudible].
All right.
My friends sent me to practice,
practice calming shit.
Dude.
I can get right to the end of this.
All right.
This is what you gotta do.
You do both.
Don't quit your fucking job.
This is what you do,
right?
Five minutes of material and go sign up for an open mic and try standup comedy.
Okay?
That way if you go up and you eat your fucking balls and you hated it and it was
humiliating and you don't ever want to do it again,
you're not going to be sitting at your cubicle going,
what if you're going to be like,
no,
I tried it.
I bombed and I didn't like it.
Now if you go down there and you go up and even if you bomb but you still like
it,
you know,
which is a major fucking sign.
If you bomb and you still like,
I want to come back.
Then just keep coming back and keep doing that and just balancing it out.
And I,
but I,
you need to have a major talk with your wife and just say,
listen,
this is going to kill me if I never try this.
I,
but I promise to you,
I promise you that there's going to be no let down me as a husband or a father
here.
Um,
but there will be,
you know,
a couple of nights a month at first just to see.
I just have to know.
Okay.
And um,
then if she goes,
well,
you're making mid six figures and blah,
blah,
blah.
That's when you start pointing out all the morons that you listen to one podcast
that are making fucking money in this business.
Okay.
And I'm telling you,
dude,
if I can do it,
anybody can fucking find a place.
Uh,
well,
not anybody.
You know what I mean?
If you have any sort of fucking talent,
you can do it.
Jay,
I've worked,
Stu,
I'd like to say real quick before you say that,
because he's mentioned money a couple of times like these,
like I,
and then I don't know,
I don't have any frame of reference of how much money I could make if I could
make any or Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
The one thing is you can't,
I don't think you can worry about that going into it because you know,
you've seen them every day in the clubs,
in La and everywhere else within five or seven years you can be a millionaire
and then you know what,
five or seven years after that,
nobody wants to work you.
I mean cause it's a,
it's a,
but then
all goes down to what he was talking about and it goes,
it goes all down to that living within your means,
paying down your house,
not carrying credit card debt.
Like,
dude,
I to fuck these fucking people.
Yeah.
Doesn't mean that you don't get smart doing that.
And then still not this people die in five years after you were making a
million.
You know what I mean?
In this business,
in this business,
people in the NFL,
in the NFL,
NBA,
and in show business with their own TV shows living paycheck to paycheck because
they're doing the exact same fucking thing that you do just at a much grander
scale.
And everybody goes,
how the fuck could you fuck that up?
And you know,
most people saying that are doing it at that look at their level now it's,
look,
if you,
if you have not making any fucking money,
I get living paycheck to paycheck.
But if you know you don't need that extra pair of sneakers,
you don't need another flat screen TV.
You don't even need a fucking TV.
There's ways you got to get out in front of it.
Yeah.
If,
if when you're young,
you got to start building up a fucking nest egg and you got to get on the
Internet,
read some books,
figure out how fucking evil the game is so you at least know how it's played.
So you can like take on as little water as you can and he can fucking stay
afloat because,
because you know there's a lot of people want to do other things in there.
They just got a ball and chain around their fucking neck and it financially and
they just got themselves in this thing.
So if you're in that situation just immediately start fucking dude,
I ever have a yard sale and just start selling shit,
downsize in my life.
And if I had to take two years off from fucking live in the the American dream
and just paying myself down and getting out of that fucking debt,
I would do it and I would start over again because that shit,
oh fucking keep you up at night
said,
I mean this guy talks so he's like,
you know,
he is going to make money but,
but what I'm saying is like just be aware of the idea of the money of it isn't
why,
because maybe anxiety make making mid six figures in what he's doing.
95% of the times you can't go backwards.
Usually we'll probably what he does for living at,
once he hits one 50 year,
the next step is one 65 to 200 year.
That's not the formula.
In standup comedy,
you can make one 52 years in a row and guess what?
By year four,
you're making 45.
No,
but this is the great thing about standup comedy though.
Or you can make 2 million,
no boards.
What's great about standup comedy though is you never unemployed.
True.
You're never unemployed.
You never employed and less,
but unless you,
you want to,
uh,
unless your ego gets in the way where like say,
you know,
you were selling,
selling out clubs,
you know,
so you just come in and do on Thursday through Saturday,
I'm not doing the Sunday show.
If it starts to taper off and they want you to do too,
the Sunday show and you refuse to do it and you start doing that shit rather
than being like,
I got to get it going again,
then,
then you can get yourself in fucking trouble.
But like,
um,
you know,
I don't know how actors do it.
I don't know how musicians do what that Shit's fucking Harper being a standup
comic.
Once you start,
you know,
you've established yourself,
you've made a name for yourself.
If you never take your foot off the gas pedal and you just keep pushing yourself
and you keep doing that,
like you,
you can have the closest thing to job security.
But even in his world,
dude,
like they could downsize.
They should fucking kick him out.
And then he,
then he's at that weird age.
So,
dude,
this is my advice.
Don't quit your job.
But I would definitely just start doing it.
And there's nothing wrong if you always keep your job and you just do standup
because you like doing it,
or you started a sketch group with your friends and just have fun.
Um,
and don't listen to any other comedians who were saying like,
you're taking my stage time.
It isn't their stage time.
All right?
It's an art.
It doesn't belong to anybody.
It's supposed to make you happy and other people happy when you do it.
So that,
that's what I would do.
All right,
so good luck to you,
sir.
You're not a nervous cons.
Okay.
You're a fucking normal human being.
Stop being hard on yourself.
So there you go.
There's the podcast for this week.
I'm like,
I mentioned,
uh,
me and Jason Lawhead,
we're going to be at the boulder theater in boulder.
I believe that's,
I can't even wait to say that word when I get there.
Isn't that the girl that's like a voiceovers dream is boulder that can go from
like a beer commercial
all the way to like a murder mystery show.
Like that quiet town of boulder who was murdered.
Or You could be like,
you know,
when we were the Rockies with cold water or bold or you know,
like you have a watch that shit when they'd sit there and uh,
I love those murder mystery shows
and they'd just be like,
it was a quiet town.
That's my dream
for the July.
But the underbelly,
I want to do that every day.
That's how you doing the downturn.
This wasn't supposed to happen in this town.
A town where they keep the doors are locked at night.
You knew your neighbor.
People sat on porches,
drinking tulip bothers the perfect name for,
oh,
that's a voiceover three boulder,
Colorado,
September 4th pikes peak center,
Colorado Springs on the sixth look for me and Jason were a,
we're going to be looking for a tailgate.
If you guys have any information,
if you got,
if you throw it down and you do it right and you got some extra Breskit or
something and I'll be cheering for the Broncos cause all the years I cheered
against them when they were playing the actual browns.
Now they're playing the old browns who are my division and I will definitely be
cheering for the Broncos because I've been so mean to Peyton manning over the
years.
And now you get that thing where you're getting sentimental cause he's in the
final third and yet you don't.
That's like doctor Jay.
I didn't hate him as much.
Magic [inaudible] Jeter,
I hated Jordan killed us and as he got older I'm like Ha,
I'm going to miss that guy.
Yeah.
Am I saying that guy?
So the paint that I've ever had with Lebron,
but I missed due to flip Ron.
They talk about Lebron look coming back to clean.
No going to the Lakers as a joke over.
If he goes to the Lakers and that championship is celebrating,
then you know what I want.
You know what,
you know what they should do.
They should literally have like the pregame for that should literally be like
eighth graders playing first graders and tackle football
and then doing long fucking interviews with the eighth graders when they won.
Talking about coming together as a team and all that type of shit.
I'm telling you dude,
like who got a Lakers when,
where some stupid number like 49 or something.
You know what I mean?
Like you know,
just I,
it'll be just the worst.
It's what sports has become and your,
I saw some more on it was trying to say that pile on teams are not a new thing.
It was so dumb.
He like,
he was trying to sit there saying like talking about like those Laker teams in
the 80s and the Celtics like to those teams were built,
built.
Yeah.
Two trades and traps.
They,
it wasn't like magic and James Worthy sat on a yacht during the off season
going,
hey man,
what'd be great if we all played in same team fucking moron.
The Guy,
this guy at the top 10 sports myths.
And he tried to say that that was his pet pile on teams where sports Smith,
it was an end.
Go back and look at the teams that didn't win it in those areas that were built
the,
I watched the hardwood classics a couple of weeks ago.
They had the 1985
all star game on the Milwaukee Bucks had four guys on the eastern,
all stars,
they won't.
Seventh Street,
seventh straight,
50 win seasons off built through the draft and trade.
And this is what the guy was saying though,
his justification that they were pylon teams despite the fact nobody piled on,
was that in the,
in the 80s the Lakers,
the Celtics,
the sixers and the Pistons were the only ones who won championships.
Everybody else was without.
And he goes,
so it was,
it was good for the league and that's in it's complete bullshit because what
they didn't realize was that despite the fact that the bucks never came through,
they had Sidney Moncrief.
Yep.
Jack Sigma,
Terri Cummings,
Jack [inaudible].
Pressy what Jackson was on them was on the,
uh,
the signup for it.
But no,
he came to the box in the mid eighties.
Honix he was in,
uh,
he was,
um,
he came to the box back then.
Back then you had,
you had blockbuster trades like when Moses Malone went to the sixers did,
there would be in a k or we're Kareem went to the Lakers,
but there wasn't like what happened in Boston.
We're just overnight too.
We went from the worst team in the League to winning the championship and we
fucking go.
We got Kevin Garnett for nothing from Kevin Mchale.
That should have been investigated the same way.
The way the Lakers got,
uh,
Pau Gasol and Jerry Jerry West was,
was with fucking,
uh,
is that who it was was with the fucking
Grizzle Grizzlies?
Yeah.
Like both those trades were complete
behind enemy lines.
Bullshit.
And then we got ram round.
That's why I wasn't upset when when ray went to Miami,
I was like,
we'll do,
that's how we got him.
He wasn't ours.
He wasn't a Celtic keep it.
I still look at him like he's one of the great,
the great step played for the organization,
but it's,
it's a different thing where he was like the,
you become like a mercenary.
Like they just,
they're bringing you in.
A couple of weeks ago,
Lebron had that,
there was this big news that he takes,
he's going to add another hour to the podcast.
I'll end with this.
A couple of weeks ago,
Lebron had this big news where he tweeted out his top three players of all
times.
I,
some big publication tweeted at him like,
Hey Lebron,
you've never talked about that.
Tada.
So everybody would on the edge of their seat,
what's his big dream?
So he named it,
I'm not going to be mad at the list in a,
in a way because it's hard.
It's so subjective.
Three players really.
He said,
Larry Bird,
which I thought that was pretty cool.
Birds a bit greatest small forward in the history of the game.
I don't know if I'd put them on the greatest three lists.
Uh,
he said,
uh,
Michael Jordan.
Yeah,
that's great.
That's easy.
And Doctor Jay,
I love Doctor J.
That's great.
Maybe that's easy,
but how do I tweet back to them?
I go,
really key.
How do you leave Kareem off the list?
I got a guy won six titles,
one of which in Milwaukee,
the boot.
I go,
that's kind of like a guy winning one in Cleveland.
Wow.
That'd be like if somebody won't want to Cleveland is what I said.
I said he won one in Milwaukee to boot.
How many have they won since?
That'd be like somebody wanted one in Cleveland.
That's what I tweeted at him.
Jesus quest.
Very clever way of saying,
well thanks for thanks for leaving and buddy.
Exactly.
But I like Dr j because I love dogs.
This is why,
because the big thing with me is changing the game.
Yes.
And like it's fine and I'm fine with that.
Bet It does list.
I'm just saying,
how do you leave Karimov cream cheese?
Well,
that's the thing.
Don't buy off basketball.
If I only had three,
I would have to pick three guys who changed the game.
So it would be Jordan,
it would be Dr j,
and then I would have to be somebody else that I,
I'm not aware of from the 60s,
like a Russell.
I mean,
I mean you get,
was it Oscar Robinson who scored all the points?
Yeah,
yeah.
Ask Her was great.
I mean,
people don't realize how great Bob Pettit was.
Bob Pettit was,
uh,
I know that there's somebody from that era because that's,
that's one of those things with like standup where you had like,
like what Lenny Bruce did took it to,
first of all,
you had the Vaudeville guys,
whoever the first guys to do that.
Then you have the Lenny Bruce did.
Then you had what prior did and what prior did I feel is like what Jordan did,
what?
There's just some guys that they're geniuses at such a level that it's you,
it's,
you can't surpass it.
Yeah.
It's,
they almost take it to the end.
I would say like James Brown,
James Brown,
the,
the music that he made.
There's been a zillion funk bands after him,
but nobody ever took it to another level.
Yeah.
Never.
Jabar I don't know how you can leave tomorrow,
if any.
Was He changed the game?
He changed it.
He,
he,
he won six titles.
Magic.
Never one on one with a holiday.
I know.
Was older player ever to win?
How did he change the game?
Change the game by,
well,
first off they outlawed dunking.
Right.
But because of what it will Chamberlain NBA too though because of,
uh,
they,
well,
here's how he changed the game.
All the ends of the floor.
He was Russell Russell couldn't do what Jabar did on the offensive end.
You can say wilt Chamberlain.
Yeah,
he was dominant,
but because they moved Jabar away from the basket,
Chamberlin couldn't do anything away from the basket.
Jabbar developed the Skyhook from 20 feet out and he was just,
he was Russell on both ends of the court.
And Russell couldn't play offensively like Jabar could it not even close Jabbar.
The fact that he won oldest man ever to win a finals MVP award.
The guy won the NBA,
he won the NBA Finals Mvp at 38 I mean come on man.
In a young dude,
I'm not arguing with you.
I just like Karen.
Like seriously dude,
like got what's,
what's the name of your podcast?
By law heads court.
Yeah.
If you want to listen to a guy who really knows sports as opposed to me being
Brady Anderson calling in tomorrow,
former Oriel Brady Anderson,
first guy first.
The guy that hit 50.
So it should be an interesting conversation.
I met Brady at the Hollywood improv a few weeks ago.
Got Em in cause great duty.
You remember,
you know Dan Godfrey from uh,
Irvine and proper,
but Dan big orange.
So I'm,
I'm the,
I'm ducking in there a couple of weeks ago cause I hear a tells in towels.
I was over at the kind of store so I decant,
I wanted to see David [inaudible] said,
well the place is packed.
Quick story,
there's a line and you know the door guy I know works at implant.
I'm just squeezing by going like,
Hey,
I'm going to go on the bar and,
and try to peek my head in and see a towel.
And there's this girl like arguing with the door guy.
She's like,
well,
my friends are in there.
He's like,
I can't let you in.
It's,
it's full.
He said,
well,
my brother and I look over as,
I'm like squeaking by.
I looked and she's with Anderson,
I can pick out an athlete.
He right.
He ended his career as an Indian and I met him in Cleveland one time,
just down in the flats after a game.
He was a cool guy,
so what'd you do?
So I was like,
so she's arguing.
So I was just like,
hey man,
how you doing?
He's like,
Hey,
good.
I go,
hey man,
I'm a fan.
I'm from Cleveland.
I actually,
he's like,
oh cool man,
Brady.
I'm like,
Jason.
And he's like,
he's like,
and then she goes,
she sees it.
She's like,
do you know anybody here?
I'm like,
well,
I'm a comic when I'm not working on it.
She's like,
can you help us get in?
I'm like,
Huh?
I Dunno and I just Damn Godfrey is now did like a district manager,
but he's never thought you'd get,
you'd get them in.
I just got to end the park.
I'd like to add a man got him in.
He gave us,
it gives me his phone number.
He's like,
anytime you want to tickets.
Thanks for getting me and dude.
He gives me his phone number.
He's like,
come to Baltimore.
When can they hear him?
When picking a hearing on the pocket.
They'll be here at him this Thursday.
The podcasts will drop.
I'm interviewing him tomorrow via phone.
It'll be this Thursday.
Brady Anderson.
Then all right on la heads court.
Look for Jason Library.
Everybody got to go check a pork shoulder.
Rosebowl tailgate legend j law had just tripped over
box stig as the legend part.
All right guys,
thanks for listening and have a happy Labor Day.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
Yeah.
Oh wait,
I've got to do,
what am I doing?
I've got to do the wrap up here.
I you still there?
How many is shut it off.
I got to do the wrap up.
Ah,
fucking God damn it.
Why though?
Okay,
I'm a fucking idiot.
Where is it?
Are you serious?
You know what?
I'm actually glad half the people shut this fucking thing off.
This is just extra time at this point,
you know,
and Nice buildup.
I had a nice ending.
Now the page isn't going to load.
All right,
live reads.
Where's the wrap up though?
Wrap up.
Oh,
it's on the other thing,
right?
Oh Geez.
Here we go.
The wrap up.
Okay,
here we go.
Hey everybody.
Now that the show was over,
don't forget to sign up for your free trial of Hulu Plus Hulu plus let you binge
on thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere on your TV,
PC or smartphone or tablet.
Uh,
support this podcast and get an extended free trial of Hulu plus when you go to
the podcast page at [inaudible] dot com and click on the Hulu plus banner,
I'll go to Hulu plus.com/bill.
That's Hulu plus.com/bill.
Have a great,
uh,
holiday weekend.
I'll talk to you guys next week.